[Music]
in february 2009 president obama gave
his first address to congress
behind him was the speaker of the house
a democrat and
in the audience was the senate majority
leader also a democrat
which meant that when obama said this
health care reform
cannot wait it must not wait and it will
not wait another year
he wasn't kidding the next year his
health care bill was passed in both
houses of congress and became law
even though every single republican
voted against it
but later that year republicans won back
the majority in the house
for the rest of his presidency obama
never again passed a major piece of
legislation
then donald trump became president with
a republican house and a republican
senate
they passed his tax bill no democrats
voted for it
but in the next election democrats won
control of the house
and that was the end of trump's
legislative agenda
now joe biden is about to start his
presidency with a house controlled by
democrats
but we still don't know who will control
the senate
of the senate's 100 seats we know
republicans will have 50 and democrats
will have 48
but these we don't know yet these are
the last two races of the 2020 election
and they'll decide if the new
president's agenda will be ambitious
or compromised and they're both
happening in the same place
georgia georgia georgia at stake control
of the u.s
senate two senate runoff races that are
now the center
of the political world
in nearly every u.s state elections are
won by the candidate with the most votes
but in the state of georgia most
candidates need to reach at least
50 percent of votes to win a true
majority
when that doesn't happen in georgia the
top two candidates move on to a second
election
a runoff and everyone votes all over
again
that's what happened in november
republican senator david perdue got the
most votes in his re-election race
but he missed that 50 percent mark by
just a few thousand votes
so he and the democrat jon ossoff will
compete in a runoff election on january
5th
what's extremely unusual though is that
there were two senate races in the same
state in the same year
the other was a special election to fill
the seat of a senator who retired early
due to bad health
in this race several republicans and
several democrats ran
and no one got close to 50 so the top
two candidates republican kelly lefler
and democrat raphael warnock
now go to the runoff in the u.s
runoff elections are most common in the
south an area with a
long history of white politicians
suppressing the vote of black americans
and during the civil rights movement
runoff elections became one of the tools
to do that
in 1963 a white georgia politician named
denmark grover
proposed the runoff system after he lost
an election to what he called
negro block voting he argued that when a
black candidate runs against many
white candidates the black candidate
would get a block of black voter support
while white support would be spread out
but if you made that black candidate run
against just
one white candidate knowing that lots of
white voters wouldn't vote for a black
candidate
the white candidate would have a better
chance at winning
years later gruver was open about the
fact that his plan was
racially motivated but georgia adopted
it
in 1990 the federal justice department
sued georgia over their runoff system
they argued it had a demonstrably
chilling effect on the ability of blacks
to become candidates
but the suit failed and georgia still
does it this way
this year's special senate race features
exactly the kind of match-up the system
was designed to produce
a black candidate versus a white
candidate but georgia once a reliably
republican state
is changing organizers are getting black
voters registered in record numbers
more of its white residents are voting
democratic and in the 2020 presidential
election
a democrat won georgia for the first
time in 28 years
if both democrats win their runoffs
making it 50-50
the democratic vice president would
serve as the tie-breaking vote
so democrats would take majority control
and that would mean biden could likely
pass much of his progressive agenda
but if republicans win either seat they
win control and the republican who will
be in charge of that senate mitch
mcconnell
has vowed to not let any of biden's
legislation pass
saying think of me as the grim reaper
i need two senators from this state i
want to get something done
the voters of georgia will determine
which party runs
every committee writes every piece of
legislation and that really means
control of this country
this is a study showing how often
members of congress have voted with the
other party
you can see this used to happen fairly
often but less and less over time
today there's no longer any expectation
that the parties will be able to work
together on most issues
that's why who holds the majority is
more important than it's ever been
i will fight to expand affordable health
care a 100
trump voting record david perdue had his
chance we win georgia
we save america the 2020 election
is almost over and we know who will be
president
but until the state of georgia weighs in
we won't know what he'll
actually be able to do
[Music]